[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic
la sélection naturelle notre planète la
terre se distingue des autres planètes
par la présence à sa surface d'une
quantité exceptionnelle de formes de vie
complexes les êtres vivants sont très
diversifiés ils peuvent produire leur
énergie par photosynthèse n'être composé
que d'une seule cellule ou encore
posséder des membres articulés leur
permettant de se déplacer
chacun d'entre eux semblent étrangement
adapté à son environnement
les animaux marins par exemple semble
adapté à la nage et les végétaux en
milieu désertique semble adapté à
l'aridité de leur environnement mais
tous ces êtres vivants aussi différents
soit ils les uns des autres possèdent
une propriété en commun c'est la
présence dans leur cellule de molécules
d'adr concrètement une molécule adn est
un enchaînement très long
de plus petites molécules des
nucléotides les nucléotides se présente
sous quatre types différents
à t g et c'est à la façon des
ordinateurs qui stocke l'information
avec des 0 et des 1
ces quatre types de nucléotides compose
d'un langage qui va permettre de stocker
l'information nécessaire au
développement de l'être vivant à la
façon d'un alphabet les molécules à tgc
vont s'enchaîner les unes après les
autres formant l'équivalent de mots et
de phrases de sorte à décrire les
propriétés de base d'un individu
prenons par exemple notre espèce l'être
humain au départ lors de sa conception
un être humain est formé que d'une seule
cellule
mais cette unique cellule est bien
particulière elle contient en son coeur
des molécules d'adr qui renferme déjà
toute l'information nécessaire au
développement futur de l'individu le
fait qu'ils possèdent des bras une tête
la couleur de ses yeux ou celle de ses
cheveux toutes ces informations sont
déjà encodés à l'intérieur de cet unique
cellule
au fil du temps la cellule va se
dupliquer se multiplier jusqu'à avoir un
individu entier ce processus présente
deux particularités extrêmement
importante
la première l hérédité l'adn d'un enfant
consiste en une contribution à parts
égales de chacun de ses deux parents
l'enfant va hériter des caractéristiques
génétiques de son père et de sa mère
et pour chacune d'entre elles c'est
l'une ou l'autre qui va se manifester
l'enfant va par exemple présenter la
forme des oreilles de son père mais la
capacité à digérer le lactose de sa mère
chaque enfant est donc un nouvel
individu différent des autres qui
correspond en quelque sorte un mélange
de ses deux parents la deuxième
particularité importante est ce qu'on
appelle la variabilité au moment de la
conception d'un enfant
les cellules reproductrices départ en
spermatozoïdes et ovules peuvent
contenir des petites mutations
en effet au cours de leur vie des
mécanismes complexes liés à la
réplication des cellules introduisent
des erreurs qui altèrent légèrement
l'information qui est codée dans ces
cellules ces petites mutations vont se
transmettre à l'enfant ce qui va parfois
engendrer chez lui l'apparition de
nouvelles caractéristiques
pour illustrer ces deux propriétés
imaginons un univers dans lequel se
trouvent des oiseaux ont les immergent
au sein d'un environnement bien
particulier de l'herbe verte dans notre
univers la moitié des oiseaux et de
couleur verte
l'autre moitié est de couleur blanche on
va s'intéresser à l'évolution de leur
population
à chaque génération les oiseaux blancs
et verts vont se reproduire
un oiseau dont les parents sont de deux
couleurs différentes va soit hérité de
la couleur de sa mère soit de celle de
son père de cette façon au cours du
temps la population globale va changer
mais elle continuera de présenter
environ une moitié d'oiseaux blancs et
une moitié d'oiseaux vert
c'est alors qu'un groupe de prédateurs
fait son apparition ce sont des chats
dont l'unique but est de manger les
oiseaux heureusement pour les oiseaux
vers leurs teintes leur permet de se
camoufler dans l'herbe et de ne pas être
vus par les chats mais d'autre part
malheureusement pour les oiseaux blancs
la couleur blanche est désormais devenu
un handicap elle les rend très visible
dans l'herbe est donc très facile à
attraper au fil des générations
presque tous les oiseaux blancs vont se
faire manger avant même d'avoir pu se
reproduire
ce sont donc pratiquement que les
oiseaux vers qui vont réussir à se
reproduire et en héritant de leurs
parents la plupart des oisillons qui
vont naître seront ainsi de couleur
verte
le temps s'écoule et au bout de quelques
générations seulement les oiseaux de la
population sont presque tous de couleur
verte
il reste tout de même quelques individus
blanc qui ont réussi à survivre ou à se
reproduire
ou alors qu'ils sont nés de parents vers
mais avec des mutations génétiques leur
donnant cette couleur c'est alors que
notre environnement subit à nouveau une
modification dramatique il se met à
neiger et l'herbe devient blanche
c'est un événement tragique pour les
oiseaux car maintenant que l'herbe est
blanche
les individus de couleur verte sont plus
facilement repérables par les chats
c'est désormais à leur tour de se faire
manger alors que les quelques oiseaux de
couleur blanche qui était auparavant
handicapés par leur couleur sont
désormais très bien camouflés dans la
neige cette fois-ci de génération en
génération
ce sont les oiseaux vers qui vont avoir
du mal à se reproduire ton disque en
transmettant la couleur de leur plume à
leurs enfants les oiseaux blancs vont
devenir majoritaires dans la population
l'espèce a évolué la couleur globale de
la population a progressivement changé
en réaction aux variations de
l'environnement
et à l'intervention des prédateurs c'est
ce phénomène qu'on appelle la sélection
naturelle pour un environnement bien
spécifiques
certains individus sont plus aptes que
les autres à survivre ou à se reproduire
la pression du climat de la nourriture
ou des prédateurs va faire disparaître
les autres individus qui vont avoir du
mal à se reproduire et les
caractéristiques des individus avantages
et vont se transmettre à leurs enfants
jusqu'à devenir majoritaires dans la
population c'est par exemple de cette
façon que de petits mammifères
terrestres ont progressivement évolué
mutation après mutation millions
d'années après millions d'années pour
donner naissance à des animaux
complètement aquatiques les baleines
mais le phénomène de l'évolution des
espèces ne se termine jamais ils
continuent encore aujourd'hui de
modifier progressivement l'apparence des
êtres vivants sur terre à coup de hasard
et de sélection le principe de la
sélection naturelle est d'ailleurs très
utilisés aujourd'hui dans le domaine de
l'intelligence artificielle
certains algorithmes moderne reproduise
cette mécanique de mutation puis de
sélection pour entraîner des
intelligences artificielles et les
rendre de plus en plus performantes en
fonction des tâches qu'on leur demande
d'accomplir
de façon plus générale la sélection
naturelle s'inscrit dans un ensemble de
mécanismes logique qui peuvent
s'appliquer à une grande variété de
domaines
dès lors qu'on retrouve les trois
critères suivants une forme des rites
habilités de génération en génération
une forme de variabilité des petites
mutations qui viennent créer de
nouvelles caractéristiques et une
certaine pression sélective qui va
favoriser certains individus aux dépens
des autres on peut alors imaginer
retrouver ces trois critères dans tout
un tas de domaines différents
en ce qui concerne la musique par
exemple un musicien au moment de
composer un nouveau morceau va
s'inspirer des autres musiciens qui
l'ont précédé et des morceaux plus
anciens qui l'ont influencé
mais le morceau va également présenter
des petites variations des nouveautés
introduites par le compositeur qui le
rendent unique
enfin au fil du temps le morceau va
potentiellement être un succès auprès du
public et de la sorte influencer les
générations suivantes
ou alors au contraire il va faire peu
d'audience et être progressivement
oublié dans ce cas c'est le public qui
va agir comme environnement de sélection
ce mécanisme peut donc dans une certaine
mesure expliqué l'évolution des styles
musicaux à travers les âges pour finir
ce mécanisme s'applique également dans
une certaine mesure à des objets
cosmiques de notre univers on peut par
exemple penser aux étoiles qui meurt
après avoir consommé leur carburant mais
laisse derrière elle un nuage de matière
qui va donner naissance à de nouvelles
étoiles
il est même possible d'imaginer que ce
phénomène s'applique à notre univers
tout entier celui ci pourrait n'être
qu'un individu parmi une population
d'autres univers qui hériterait
génération après génération des lois
fondamentales des univers précédent mais
avec de légères variations
ceux ci auraient tendance à terme à
sélectionner certains univers plutôt que
d'autres
c'est une idée spéculative mais très
intéressante à imaginer on parle de
sélection naturelle cosmologique
[Musique]